hey guys I'm Dave filling in for the one
and only Lucy James for this week's
reality check put on your Sunday best as
we're taking inspiration from games like
fallout 4 and the sims and looking at
the surprising effects that a tire can
have on your charisma your perceived
intelligence and even your perception of
strength in the midst of daydreaming
about achieving a better life without
actually having to put the F in to get
it I got thinking it's it possible to
improve your real-life stats with a
piece of magical gear just like in
role-playing games well let's start with
something we've all had to suffer
through school education the pursuit of
intelligence wandering around the wastes
in Fallout 4 it's possible to use
clothing and accessories to increase
your intelligence staff which is useful
for hacking those pesky computer
terminals now wearing similar attire in
the real world won't actually make you
more computer savvy but believe it or
not it can increase your ability to pay
attention and even accurately answer
tests and puzzles Adam Galinsky a
professor at the Kellogg School of
Management led a study in what's called
enclosed cognition which looked at the
effect clothing has on our cognitive
processes the tests had subjects wear a
coat that they believed belonged to a
doctor and were then asked to take a
test to measure their levels of
attention
the results were extraordinary those who
wore the coat made about half as many
errors as the ones who didn't according
to professor kolinsky this is all due to
what the clothing represents a second
test or another selection of people were
wearing the exact same coat but thought
it belonged to a painter did not result
in any meaningful decrease in errors
interestingly the coat needed to be worn
not just observed to create these
special powers so no it can't just sit
in your inventory word of warning though
don't walk into a hospital pick up the
nearest lab coat and pretend you're dr.
Jewett it really really doesn't work
there's not quite as much brain trickery
when it comes to increasing one's
charisma you probably don't have time to
spend six hours talking to yourself in
mirror as I forced many a sin to do but
doing so once a day in the real world
can actually lead to an increase in
self-confidence and to your charisma
it's called the mirror technique
creative name I know
and according to Olivia Fox Caban a
self-help author who touched some
subjects of self-confidence this
slightly mad process can help shape a
cool part of your charisma the idea is
to spend five minutes every day in front
of a mirror the bigger the better put a
smile on your face and start saying
positive things to your reflection
things like I believe in myself and
every day I get 1% better make it a
daily habit there are some arguments
over whether this technique actually
works but those who do say it can
increase your sense of presence your
feeling of power and you're perceived
warmth now I know the gym isn't the
nicest place in the world but you still
want to be stronger than your friends
right well all it takes believe it or
not is a Superman costume to believe
you're super strong professor Karen pine
from the University of Hartford sure
explains it a study where clothes can
affect what we believe we are able to
achieve both mentally and physically
in the study pine asked a selection of
students half of which were wearing a
Superman t-shirt how much they think
they could lift the result well the
study showed that on average a students
dressed as Clark Kent's alter ego
estimated that they could lift more than
those in plain clothes so way all it
takes to actually think you're way
stronger than everyone else is a
Superman t-shirt
well even crazier when wearing that
Kryptonians attire students actually
rated themselves as more likeable and
superior to their mortal counterparts so
as it turns out there may actually be
something to me wearing my lucky pair of
tighty whities after all maybe the next
time I head to the gym I'll see an
entire wardrobe of the Justice League in
Avengers in the weight room who knows
anyway I'm off to talk to myself in
front of a mirror for a few hours but
before I go I want to know if you had
any experiences like this do you have an
outfit that makes you feel powerful do
you feel like the bee's knees when
you're wearing a suit or have you
actually had any success with chatting
to your reflection every morning I'd
love to find out your views so make sure
you leave them in the comments section
below or you can find me on twitter at a
regular Dave and Lucy we'll return next
episode for another reality check